le nordina est un arbuste à fleurs
originaire d'extrêmement rien
à certaines périodes de l'année ces
feuilles dégagent une odeur qui font
tourner la tête
comme on a la tête qui tourne
juste avant d'appuyer sur la détente
j'ai une faveur à vous demander je vous
écoute ma petite nièce j'aimerais
beaucoup que vous la preniez à vos côtés
comme stagiaire elle a abandonné ses
études et depuis elle a de mauvaises
fréquentations tu apprendras à jardiner
est-ce que tu es satisfaite de la vie
que tu mènes en ce moment pourquoi tu
veux savoir ça
tu racontes pas mal de conneries mais il
y a un truc dont tu parles jamais ah
ouais de quoi de toi
[Musique]
il y a pas grand chose à dire
c'était il y a bien longtemps
ils ont beau être mort personne t'as
oublié
est-ce que tu as déjà tué quelqu'un
[Musique]
pourquoi tu dis ça
enlève ton chandail
tu es impertinentes seulement sa voix
moi je suis la reine des Corses
jardinage est une croyance en l'avenir
la croyance que les choses se
dérouleront comme privé qui t'a frappé
tu vas faire quoi
la nouvelle vie commence mon vieux
et construit cette vie
je me suis fixé toutes ces règles
[Applaudissements]
que l'heure est venue dans transgresser
une
[Musique]